اثمار بن غفير وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيليه ينتمي لليمين الديني المتطرف
في هوايه راس حزب العظمه اليهوديه وشارك
اكثر من مره في عمليه اقتحام للمسجد
الاقصى ولد بالقدس المحتله فيما يغير عام
76 وهو من سكان مستوطنه كريات اربع
المقامه على اراضي الخليل جنوبيه ضفه
الغربيه بدا نشاطه في الاحزاب المتطرفه في
سن السادسه عشر في حزب مرورا بحركه كاخ
بزعامه الحامل
وصولا الى حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه الذي
ادخله الى الكنيست في ابريل 2020 حول
الانضمام الى نقابه المحامين لكن طلبه رفض
بسبب سجله الجنائي وتبرطه في انشطه لليمين
المتطرف وسمح له لاحقا في 2012
بفكره ان العرب في فلسطين اعداء يجب
اخراجهم بالعنف ولا يقبل التعايش معهم
اشتهر بوضعه على جدار منزله لصوره صاروخ
جولد ستايل مج في الحرم الابراهيمي التي
راح ضحيتها 10 المصلين ووصفه بالبطل ثم
ازالها لترشح لعضويه الكنيست كما اودين
بالتحريض على العنصريه واستمر في تمثيل
مستوطننا متورطين في بناء مستوطنه غير
قانونيه وسماهم ملح الارض ودفع في 2015 عن
مراهقين التهم بالمشاركه في حادثه حرق
متعمده لافراد عائله دوابشه بقريه دوما
اقتحم بمعيه مستوطنين مره عند حي الشيخ
جراح وتسبب في تفجير الوضع فيه وفي القدس
وجها له الاتهام اكثر من 50 مره بارتيكا
باشكال مختلفه من التحريض لكن كانت تتمت
بريئاته في كل مره الولايات المتحده نادت
بمشاركه بين غفير في مراسم تكريم للحمام
المتطرف ما يركانا وكان موقع اكسيوس نقل
عن اداره ايضا انها لن تتعامل مع بنت غفير
وزيرا في الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده